without a fixed address no bank account
but without a bank account it's
impossible to rent a home this vicious
circle is well known to foreign workers
students homeless people and migrants
there are about 58 million people in
Europe without a bank account MEP s one
basic bank accounts for all at a
reasonable price and they're insisting
on transparency the bank has to inform
you before you open the account about
all the costs and the interest you have
to pay if Member States approve the
first basic account should be set up
within two years the red air Terrapin de
Louisiana crawfish ragweed or the Asian
predatory wasp all these animals insects
and plants are invasive alien species
there are an estimated 12,000 such
species in Europe and their numbers are
rapidly increasing they are a threat to
euros biodiversity and they can be
harmful to people leading to an
estimated economic loss of 12 billion
euros per year series of measures
adopted by any piece focuses on limiting
their numbers and avoiding new invasions
in the future
Emme piece took to the floor in plenary
for the last time before the European
elections for a roundtable to discuss
lessons from the first world war 100
years on and to reflect on Europe's
future all the presidents of political
groups spoke many for the last time in
their careers some took the opportunity
to call for a political union and for
Europe to stand against nationalism
never again two simple words expressing
a whole history and hope for the future
the only sustainable defense is by
strengthening the European Union sea
level sukham Assyrian populist
eurosceptic new roman colorful Goethe
our sons others saturate our - la la la
la la la since we published a tragedy
d'Ivoire
we require our federal sale of
you